[Music]
today's question comes from james in
california he says dave out of curiosity
specifically how did you make your first
million
after your bankruptcy hmm that's a good
ques i don't even know the story
i'm not sure i do
take us back i'll have to think about it
so this was back in 88 so i filed
bankruptcy in september of 88 and what i
did after that was i went back to doing
real estate deals only i couldn't
uh
buy real estate anymore because i had no
credit and no money so no one what i
would do is tie up a deal and then sell
the contract to another investor that
used to be a competitor of mine but
we're friends and so i did you know
what you might call a dry flip in other
words i sell the contract positions so i
go contract for a house that's worth 200
000 i would contract for it for 110 and
sell it to a buddy of mine for 10 000
bucks and he could close on you have 120
in it right it's still two hundred
thousand dollar house so i'm still doing
foreclosure deals i got back to doing
six figures in 89 again i was back
making over a hundred thousand a year
doing that
but i had a bunch of irs debt to clean
up because that doesn't bankrupt and a
few other things to clean up
and it took about a year and a half two
years to clean that up so i'm trying to
think that maybe i kept doing that um
i'm trying to think
if i got my net worth to a million again
before we started doing financial peace
i might not have
so had you started this actually really
starting this business slowed that down
because i made less the first year i did
the i did financial peace it was called
life after death i was doing the radio
show the radio show was losing money
um
my taxable income was in half the first
i made 120 000 a year before i made 60
000 a year after wow first year opened
this business
and my income went in half so that
slowed it down
so it would have been a couple of years
after i got this going
uh you know we're starting to get a
little bit of income out of this income
came bomb back up over time of course
because you started selling the original
financial piece book and are you doing
seminars and you know the 13 15 week
however long it was yeah
sharon and i lived on nothing
even though we were out of debt by then
i mean we paid off the bankruptcy we
paid off the uh everything we were
completely clear
but we were just done and so we just
lived on nothing and just piled up money
and uh because we wanted both wanted the
security of that margin and so
what
how did i make my first million so
uh income
and thrift
is how i did it so it was not in the
stock market at that point no no i mean
well i had some i had uh i mean we had
our 401k not 401k we had roth iras not
they weren't even roth iras in those
days just irs i had iras in those days
ago and kids college funds going um and
i'm just chunking money and stuff like
that and that
didn't even have any real estate except
our own got the house paid off
uh so yeah i was i was probably three or
four years into this business
before i hit another network it was
mostly earned income from just mostly
earned income and not spending any of it
yeah none of it i mean we didn't do
anything
we're still driving junk cars we're
still
way past what we teach people to do
we teach you once you get to baby steps
three four five
six or four five six that you can
lighten up and save up and buy a car and
lighten up save up and go on vacation we
didn't
we didn't we just piled up at what point
were the baby steps developed to where
you were you were following them
uh
post bankruptcy oh i didn't follow them
uh post bankruptcy because they did i
hadn't invented them i mean i hadn't
laid all that out when i started
teaching when i started learning
after the bankruptcy god's ways of
handling money what the bible says and
grandma's ways these basic principles
live on lesson you make
always be generous live on a written
plan
um
always be saving and investing
and no debt at all and those basic five
principles when i started living those
out and then started trying to get other
people to live them out they would start
to say okay yeah but where do i start
they needed it
i started a little counseling ministry
at our church i started teaching a
sunday school class on those materials
and people would say okay so what do you
do first man i mean do you do you do you
do you do you get out of debt first or
do you put money in your in your
retirement first and um
you know but by then i was sure that the
bigger blocker because i'd experienced
it personally was debt that if you could
get out of debt then you don't have any
payments now you've got money to build
net worth which is what happened to me
yeah okay you know i got out of debt
and with a bankruptcy and then paying
off the irs and the other stuff um and
then once all that was cleared as long
as i made money and didn't spend it i
could build a net worth i could build i
could build a pile of money and that's
what i did and so i i thought okay we
got to get people out of debt first but
the paying off the house was
too big a thing
to put in the early stages okay first
thing's a thousand dollars right and
then pay off the house is the second
thing so we separated the house debt
from the other debt and put it at the
end yeah over in baby step six
and we knew that you didn't need to
start investing in your 401k until you
had an emergency fund because i was
running into people all the time that
had no money except in their retirement
and then they'd get in a pinch and cash
out their retirement
and let me tell you a 401 k is a lousy
emergency fund because when you cash it
out you get your taxes plus a 10
hit you know it's a 30 or 40 hit
cashing out your 401k to fix your
transmission
or to pay the house payment because you
got laid off
and uh you know whatever the emergency
is a 401 k is a lousy rainy day fund so
funding up the 401 i get a match i know
but you're broke
i don't care if you get a match you're
freaking broke and you're going to use
the 401k when something bad happens
because you got no money so we bet baby
step 3 is invented actually baby step
one wasn't there you were just going get
out of that get out of debt it was get
out of debt do the emergency fund and
and what would happen is as people were
working that baby step two
something would come along that was
little
like a a tire would blow out or
something or a kid would get sick and
it's a 600 700 thing or something and
that little six or seven hundred dollar
thing would take all the wind out of
their cells and they'd quit they would
stop their debt snowball so we figured
out that we gave him a little bit of
breathing room a starter emergency fund
and baby step one was born but the
original baby steps when i first started
teaching them there wasn't so this
evolved over your experience coaching
people being aware
not in 25 or years but i mean but but it
evolved over a period of time in the
early days of massaging this material
and learning how to do it it evolved but
no i didn't follow the baby steps they
weren't there all i knew was i'd read
the bible and they said don't borrow
money and i've been bankrupt so i
figured out that was the truth right so
i don't borrow money anymore bomb i'm
done you know and i always have an
emergency fund why because sharon will
leave if i don't have one you know it's
that simple she's not going to be
without money again she's had enough of
that she was terrorized by that yeah
she's not going back so you get you know
you get the whole security gland issue
around the emergency fund that all pops
up that's such an interesting question
james thank you in california thank you
very much because i hadn't even thought
about it i never thought about where the
first million
came from um
and then uh
and then you know
fast forward several years i had a lot
of money by then and 2008 hit and we
bought
oh man we bought
probably a hundred million dollars worth
of real estate for 15 million dollars
wow
and so and you know it all came back of
course and then some so that real estate
has been a big part of the building
equations well like the way beyond the
first million or even 10 million you
know by then i had net worth 10 20
million dollars probably but uh i dumped
every i you know we we cleaned the table
off we took the chips off the table when
the when the real estate dove in 2008
and you could buy it for 15 cents on the
dollar and i still got all of that i
never sold any of it so um
that was a home run but the first
million is the hardest yeah by far wow
by far and these principles once you got
these baby steps dialed in and over time
you went oh it works but you know what
i'm from baby steps i didn't i did not
even follow the baby steps millionaires
i think path because
we were more intense than the baby steps
in terms of we didn't do nothing until
we got back up there
and um
the other thing i didn't do is i
i did get the house paid off because i
don't borrow money um but the um
but the 401k hadn't had time
to germinate the roth iras didn't have
time to germinate and grow and compound
and so they weren't that big a part of
it it was just literally make income
spend nothing make income spend nothing
until you get the pain far enough in the
rear view mirror
and then we can move forward but that
was a whole lot more intense
and raw than
than i ask other people to do to get
there baby steps millionaire is more the
formula to get there so well thanks for
taking us back very interesting thank
you james that's good stuff this is the
ramsey show